Welcome aboard this Air Middle-earth flight.
Before we set out on our journey, I would like to impart a story of safety.
Even if you fly with us often, be sure to keep a sharp eye on the briefing.
Make sure your belongings are hidden away in the compartments above or under the seat before you.
All travelers must keep a watchful eye on the lighted signs and follow crew instructions.
If the seat belt sign is on, sit yourself down and fasten your seat belt quick smart.
Be sure that it's snug across your hips, but not so tight as to lose the feeling in your legs.
If you're in the Skycouch row, there are special seat belt instructions in your seat pocket.
We recommend keeping your seat belt fastened throughout the journey.
Should you need to explore, it can always be undone.
If an oxygen mask should fall before you, simply pull down on the mask, place over your nose and mouth...
...and tighten by pulling the elastics on both sides.
Oxygen will flow through the mask automatically.
If there are young ones around you, be sure to put your mask on before helping them.
Keep a sharp eye as there may be others who need your help.
Mordor.
Should an emergency occur during takeoff or landing, place your hands on your head,...
...with your elbows on the outside of your thighs, whilst keeping your feet flat on the floor.
You can also brace yourself on the seat in front of you.
My precious.